i've recently been reading a lot about
the kgb about the fsb so i've
several things sparked my curiosity so
one i'm traveling to ukraine and to
moscow
and because of that i started to sort of
ask practical questions of myself just
travel and all those kinds of things so
started reading a lot about the kgb jack
barski has a book on this i talked to
him
uh and you start to realize you probably
looked into some of this but you just
start to realize
the scale
of surveillance manipulation now a lot
of them
also talk about the incompetence of
those organizations the usual
bureaucracy creeps in but the point is
it seems like
there's no
line they're not willing to cross
for the purpose of gathering
intelligence
for the purpose of controlling people in
order to gather intelligence now this is
mi6
fsb
there's not much information about the
fsb or the gru but the kgb so we're
always like 20 years behind or more
on the actual information and so i
started to
wonder so i have not officially been
contacted by any intelligence agency
but i started to wonder well
did i is there somebody i know that's
doing that
undercover
cia or undercover
fsb undercover anything
you probably do
have you asked yourself this question
yeah for sure yeah people that have been
on my podcast
yeah for sure do you think there was
actually a guest that may have been 100
oh man i would imagine would you know
i have suspicions do you care is this
i mean
it depends on what they're attempting to
do
right like if i felt like there was some
deception involved and they were trying
to use the podcast to manipulate
uh a narrative in a deceptive way to
trick people into things
yeah i would care but this is exactly
what those are the kind of things they
do they do plant narratives yeah
i mean i would imagine
if you have the number one podcast in
the world
that people would want to infiltrate
that
yeah there's probably meetings in all
major intelligence agencies about okay
what are the large platforms
how do we just
how do we spread the message yeah well i
mean that's the the thing that really
emerged when we're talking about during
my cancellation that there's a clear
there's no objective analysis of this in
mainstream media there's clear
narratives that they're trying to push
forward
to uh whether it's to
[Music]
promote certain ideas or to diminish the
power and reach of people who are
mavericks or people who
who are
you know who are connected to a system
that you can't compromise that's where
it gets dangerous right where it gets
dangerous is when someone has the
largest reach but is also completely
detached
and
clearly uh is independent
in the sense of
independent thinking it has on whoever
he wants but your mind can still be
manipulated i guess i can i mean i guess
everybody can be manipulated a certain
way i manipulate my own mind i'm sure
too but i also spent a lot of time
thinking about what i think
you know i don't just accept things like
like the ufo thing like i was all in for
a while and now i'm like man
something smells fishy
and then i'm thinking like why here's my
problem with the ufo thing i want it to
be real so bad yeah that's my problem
with it i'm such a sucker
i want it to be real so bad you know and
that's that's a problem for me because
i'm aware of it and so then i stop and
think about like what is
what what is my desire
uh for uh
ufo truth to be exposed well it's
because it's fun
you know
that's what it is so i have a desire to
for it to be real and i mean i've talked
to uh i talked to
a bunch of folks about this so those
with connection with uh dod
and they do draw lines between people
that are full of [ __ ] and people who are
not
there's a lot of people in the public
sphere that they say are full of [ __ ]
yeah for sure and then you have to kind
of
tell the difference yeah cnn watch them
talk well i mean even yeah
on the
individuals that are like okay they're
just like using this
um in fact like people who are not full
of [ __ ] are often very quiet
right which is why you know even bob
lazar is an interesting story because he
was trying to be quiet for the longest
time
well he was worried about his own life
according to bob and that's why he went
public with it and initially the first
videos he did with george knapp they hit
his identity yeah
yeah and then he felt like that wasn't
enough and he really needed to expose
his own identity just to protect his
life
which is a great story you know so you
got to go well that seems so juicy i
want to buy into it and that's where i
get nervous you don't know you don't
know who to trust right exactly how how
do you figure that out how do you figure
out who to trust in your life you're joe
rogan a lot of people want to be close
to you cia agents fsb agents
uh
people that want i'm friends with a
former cia agent mike baker who's been
on my podcast a bunch of times allegedly
former former i think about that he's
air quotes former yeah yeah i don't
believe he's former he's problem sure he
has some connection to him i also
believe he's a good guy
but i gain a lot of very intelligent and
well-informed insights from him as to
how things work and you know
i think uh
yeah i'm sure he doesn't tell me
everything about everything but he's
told me enough where i i think i can
understand things better
from talking to him about how the way
you know
the elves
work under the machine
you